[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm
going to keep my preamble short my guest
today is jerry colonna c-o-l-o-n-n-a
on twitter at jerry colonna he is the
ceo and co-founder of reboot.io an
executive coaching and leadership
development firm dedicated to the notion
that better humans make better leaders
now for those of you who don't know
jerry's already been on the show it was
an excellent episode
and it was named the coach with the
spider tattoo we're not gonna have time
to get into
why we chose that title necessarily but
suffice to say very very detailed very
very tactical and i wanted to have him
back on for reasons that will be clear
shortly for nearly 20 years he has used
the knowledge gained as an investor one
hell of an investor an executive and a
board member for more than 100
organizations to help entrepreneurs and
others lead with humanity resilience and
equanimity
prior to his career as a coach he was a
partner with jp morgan partners the
private equity arm of jpmorgan chase
previously he led new york-based
flatiron partners which he co-founded in
1996 with partner fred wilson flatiron
became one of the nation's most
successful early stage investment
programs jerry's first leadership
position at age 25
a youngin a young whippersnapper was
editor-in-chief of information week
magazine he is the author of reboot
subtitle leadership and the art of
growing up
as i mentioned this is his second
appearance on the podcast definitely
also check out his first which goes deep
into his bio and all sorts of topics you
can find that at tim dot blog slash
jerry kelowna
again one more time
c-o-l-o-n-n-a you can find them on
twitter as mentioned andre kelowna on
linkedin of course
reboots twitter is at reboot hq and the
website for all things jerry and reboot
is
reboot.io
jerry welcome back to the show thanks
for having me tim you know it's a
bizarre experience hearing your life
played back at you like that i'm i'm
sitting there listening and i'm going
damn i'm old
and i know that's in my bio so
oh man yeah when i ever hear my bio red
back which you know i've usually crafted
carefully in third person
i'm like wow well that's the highlight
reel it's all downhill from here so it
was a very terrible way of setting
expectations yeah
so jerry i want to
explain for folks how we came to be here
today talking again
and
we're actually recording this episode
about five feet from where we recorded
the first in austin
and i remember it very very clearly
and
we reconnected
i want to say a month six weeks ago yeah
something maybe something like that and
we were we're covering a number of
different things
but uh it quickly came up that you had
just finished
a two-month sabbatical
and then you've sort of casually
mentioned that you'd done that for
how long roughly
would you say well i interrupted it last
year because of the
disruption that was 2020
but
previously it was nine straight years so
that was my tenth
two month sabbatical
okay so tenth two month sabbatical
and
i wanted to hear all about this i wanted
to dig into this
and thought it might be a great bridge
and launch pad for discussing all sorts
of things so since we covered so much of
your bio and background and
trajectory the ups and the downs
let's just jump right into it can you
perhaps begin at the beginning
with the
first sabbatical that you took and how
that came about
it's like it and if we were a tv show
you know the image would get all wavery
as he flashes back in time
okay so i've been a coach now for about
17 years
and
i came
to coaching
on the one hand very much having
been trained and
gone through methodologies that are
known as coaching
but
it would be
dishonest or not completely honest if i
didn't also say that i modeled myself
after my psychoanalyst
and as every good new yorker who's in
therapy knows august is when all the
therapists go on vacation
and so you don't want to be in new york
in august because not only does it stink
to high heaven
it's also when all of our therapists are
gone right home alone in new york city
exactly
for more on this watch the movie what
about bob
which is
which is a very good anybody who watches
the movie will get the reference
is this corn hand shucked
i continue
indeed excellent excellent movie
excellent
bill murray uh in search of his
therapist
um so
you know when i started doing this work
one of the things that i found myself
doing was feeling the repercussions if
you will
of being
fully
emotionally present more fully and
emotionally present than
most folks are in a given conversation
and i also found myself
terribly depleted
terribly exhausted
uh on a regular basis and
i remember talking to my therapist
with the idea of at first taking four
weeks off
and what i
started to do though was i started to
realize that i needed longer than that
because i know this is going to sound
really indulgent but i also wanted to
take a vacation during the middle of
sabbatical
i know that's a bit it's a bit of a
controversial statement
but
i would do things like
go to tibet for two weeks and help build
a
an orphanage
or i would take these
monumental trips i rafted the grand
canyon for the third time in
2014 with my son
and so what began is well maybe i'll
take a month and then
take two weeks of vacation
started to morph very very quickly into
you know modeling myself after my
therapist
morphed very very quickly into no i
actually need to take a pause i need to
take a break
and a funny thing happened on the way to
the forum right a funny thing happened
on the way back
i found myself being a better therapist
oh did i say that out loud a better
freudian slip there
more ways than one
a much better coach a much better coach
because i was rested and i could be
there more fully for my clients
so what what did the very first
sabbatical look like did you have any
internal conflict or pushback
oh yes i laughed it doesn't have to be
the very first it could be one of the
first but one that comes to mind well
the the the the first one that comes to
mind is can i afford this right which is
crazy but it's it's the thing that we're
programmed to think about
the second is if i go away will
everybody leave me
right which is a variation on a theme
which is will i become irrelevant
what if it turns out that all my clients
decide hey that was great
thanks very much we'll see you buddy
so there were those feelings and those
feelings can still arise for me which is
why i think when we were talking on
email i was like yeah of course tim is
kind of interested in this so
we can get to that that's what prompted
you
and then the other thing that happens
and i think a lot of folks can relate to
this based on what i hear from clients
even just about taking a long weekend or
a vacation
there's the hot and cold boredom
that can set in
you know uh
we often live with a forward momentum
inertia if you will this this pushing
forward pushing forward
and when you suddenly
stop it's it
here's a mixed metaphor it can feel like
musical chairs and the music is just
stopped and you're standing there and
you don't have a chair
and that's really disconcerting
because part of what we
do which i think leads to a significant
amount of burnout and existential
struggle
is we take meaning from motion
we take meaning from performance
and then when i take away the motion
what happens to my meaning
so you know like a good buddhist there's
a piece of me that goes oh very good
that's perfect that's exactly what we
want to have happen
but it's challenging
i want to
touch upon something that you mentioned
briefly for folks and that is can i
afford it in this question because on
one hand
depending on your expenses one could
argue that a sabbatical is a very
indulgent
1
activity but
you can also take a different
perspective and it makes me think of
a book called vagabonding by a now
friend after i read the book and gave it
to many many many many many many people
i later became friends with the author
ralph potts but
vagabonding was one of the books i took
with me when i when i took my
sabbatical of sorts in 2004 i want to
say 2004 2005 about 18 months
and did work at points throughout that
period but it was largely a walk about
and one of the points that he makes in
his book with a story is recounting part
of the movie wall street with gordon
gekko with the
brick sized cellular phone walking on
the beach
iconic film greed is good etc and
the charlie sheen character at one point
is asked by i want to say his girlfriend
or his love interest you know what do
you what are you doing this all for and
he's like well someday i'll have enough
where i can just pack it all in
and ride across china on a motorcycle
and
rolf who's done a lot of traveling said
you could work as a
toilet cleaner for
six months and save enough
to ride across china on a motorcycle for
a year
particularly if you put a pause on some
of your other expenses right and i think
about a lot of people over the pandemic
including family members of mine who
packed everything up or put it into
storage
cancelled their leases and ended up
traveling around the country trying
different cities and it cost a lot less
than their previous
fixed expenses
so depending on how you approach it and
depending on how you organize
the rest of your life hit pause or don't
hit pause on certain expenses
a sabbatical can be something that's
very very expensive but it doesn't have
to be it can also be something that's
very very
achievable and
i just wanted to yeah i mentioned that i
i think it's a really really important
conversation
we are two relatively
well-off white men
you know yakking away on a podcast right
i mean it's almost a trope at this point
and
and so we have to be very very conscious
and mindful of the fact that
we often
have choices that are not available to
everyone
and whether it's a two-month sabbatical
or an 18-month sabbatical or it's a
two-month sabbatical every year for 10
years
those are choices that are afforded us
sometimes by external forces sometimes a
combination of what we ourselves the
choices that we make we choose to spend
less money
but i think what we're also talking
about tim is is something really
important which is behind all of that
which is a mindset
in the mindset uh i think
not to do be too playful with my own
work
the mindset is the mindset behind
rebooting and resetting
let's go back and think about that word
sabbatical for a moment
you know in swapping notes with the
producer i was saying
to recall the fact that sabbatical as a
term actually is related to the same
root word of sabbath
and it is
and this is why i'm playful as well when
i talk about sabbatical taking a
vacation in the middle of my sabbatical
sabbatical is also a time
of thinking differently
of considering things differently
you know um i think it was bill gates
who popularized the term think week
it's the same
impulse
which is i'm not not working
i'm just working on something other than
what i have been compelled to work on
for the rest of the time
and
for many of our friends who are in
startup land
the thought of taking a weekend off
is as terrifying as my thought of taking
two months off
uh and that's a problem
that's a problem that
not only affects their them uh
physically
it's a problem that affects them
mentally
it's a it's a problem that actually
i would argue undermines their
leadership capabilities
and creates toxic environments
and so what we're really talking about
in this way is is this notion of can i
afford myself
a moment to pause
stand still
and think a little bit differently and
see the world a little bit differently
do you mind if i ask you some mundane
questions
i would like to
i would like to look at the plumbing
inside the cathedral for a moment and by
that i mean
we have a rare opportunity we i'm using
the royal we i mean tim ferriss is a
rare opportunity king tim
king tim
who has
deep pockets and short arms so he gets
his therapy for free on the podcast
would like to ask you tactically and
practically
what you have learned about
making sabbaticals work
what do you set up in advance what are
some of the mistakes you made early on
what are some of the things you've
learned because
we're going to get into
much more of the
deeper first principles
philosophies but i want to front load
some tactical stuff to
kind of lure people in as a as a
honeypot so so let's if you don't mind
sure focus on some of the
tactical practical anything that comes
to mind in terms of what you've learned
about making sabbaticals work for
yourself well you know you you raise a
really good point which is to think
about it in advance
and i would argue that a corollary to
that is to set expectations
and so a good example of this from my
own life was that when
my three co-founders and i set up reboot
in 2014.
two of my co-founders had previously
been clients of mine so they were aware
of this
but i said to them whatever budget we
model
for this enterprise
if it cannot afford to have me not
working not bringing in revenue
in for two months a year then i don't
want to do it
and so
if
if you think about it you think about me
not as a coach but as a ceo
stepping into the launch of a business
and from the beginning we modeled in the
notion of taking time off
now as soon as i said that
my co-founders were like hey i like that
i dare i'd like to take december off i'd
like to take this time off
and so we built a financial model
presuming not two weeks vacation but
sabbatical time
and i think that that's really critical
because that was me being in
conversation with my co-founders
now they could have said we can't afford
to do that and i would have said okay
that's great but that's how important
that is for me so i can't we have to do
something else
right
that's that setting expectation
and if
someone out there listening is
privileged enough to be able to say
in stepping into a new position
you know we we have this funny notion
especially in the tech community of
unlimited paid time off unlimited ptl
and
studies have shown that the more
unlimited is the less time people take
because
there's no sensibility around it but i
think that if we start to build into our
companies and many companies do this
we say you know after one year you get a
week of sabbatical in addition to your
vacation time after two years you get a
month of sabbatical something along
those lines
if we build that into our models
we start
to change the
perspective about ebitda
about profitability
right and if we start thinking about
this as a simply a cost of doing
business
it
builds into the structure of the
business
a humane work environment
right by law you have to build into the
structure of the business sick time
vacation time parental leave all sorts
of policies
and then periodically something
awful happens and we say okay let's
build in some mental health time
it's always after some sort of horrible
event
so jerry may i double click and zoom in
a little bit sure
to look at the sealant on the plumbing
uh just to come back to your personal
experience
what were some early
mistakes
if any come to mind that you made or
cases where you
backslid to
default behaviors
and how you perhaps
counteracted those
when you when you were when you were
kicking the tires and first taking
sabbaticals so i wouldn't say that there
was a mistake that i encountered as much
but there was a heck of a lot of
backsliding
and and there still can be a heck of a
lot of backsliding so i guess one
mistake is i
said to myself i was going to be
completely off the grid and not answer
any email
and that's just not possible i just
don't do that and so
what i did early on the first thing i
did which kind of didn't work was create
all sorts of rules i'm only going to
answer email this time or this time you
know you're smiling because because you
know your rules right and you create all
these structures around the rules and
i'm going to do this and
and for me that just doesn't work
right all it did was engender a sense of
self-criticism right because i would
quote-unquote backslide
i remember i always do an away message
and i always try to do an away message
that in some way or another inspires
other people to think about these things
right so i remember
one away message i did on sabbatical
where i talked about my plan to go to
italy for a couple of weeks
and i did that and i said you know my
plan is to do to eat more gelato than to
read email
and so if you're actually getting an
email from me i have failed
um
and and that tends to make people laugh
but what it does is it also helped me
in managing expectations so
you know
a mistake or lesson i learned was to
not turn the sabbatical into another
source of self-criticism
how did you
decide to then handle say
email so it's easy to get pulled into
the vortex and
time dilates and you realize four hours
later holy [ __ ] i've been looking at my
inbox for four hours and i'm supposed to
be eating gelato yeah you know um it's
so funny when i was thinking about our
conversation today i was thinking about
it yesterday and if i remember correctly
in our first conversation you also asked
me about email
like how do you handle email jerry
and uh or some point in our life you
asked me this question and i gave you
the perplexing answer of
just don't respond
you're like no that's it oh well we'll
come back it's it's it's slightly like
rashem
perhaps slightly different remembrance
but we can dig into that but to go to go
back to your question for a moment i
look i think the way i handle email and
that is i will scan it
and i feel super liberated if i decide
not to respond
because i've already given them a
response that says i'm not going to
respond
and so and yet there are times
where
it could be really important
to respond and so for example this this
past summer
i think i did
probably six or seven sessions
while i was on sabbatical
when you say sessions what do you mean a
session is a coaching conversation
and there was
genuine crises
that needed and that my clients needed
some help with
and i consciously
said
yes i could do that you know two o'clock
and such and such afternoon kind of
thing
boring process question how did
news get to you that that was a crisis
and important to handle
i i will allow people to text me and i
allow people to email me so i don't as i
said i scan things
but i don't and i don't have anybody
answering my notes and stuff like that i
i need to have a direct relationship
with people
so does that mean that you're scanning
each day yeah as the spirit moves you or
is uh
i think uh you know that i have a a
fairly uh healthy morning ritual where i
don't really
for the most part check email why don't
you remind people i do recall us
discussing this in episode one but just
for people who don't have that context
yeah so i'm a really early riser um
pretty much regardless of time zone i'm
up between five and six a.m every day
my morning consists of a little caffeine
and a lot of journaling
and
meditation
and
when i'm at my healthiest
i don't really glance at the phone
until
my brain is ready
and so generally speaking
it's usually the
third or fourth thing that i'm doing
and it's a glance
and then if there are things that i can
respond to quickly that just sort of
clear it out then i clear it out i'm a
zero inbox kind of guy anyway
and i suppose that all sounds quite
disciplined it doesn't feel disciplined
it just feels normal to me
and the people i'm most responsive to
are the people i love so you know my
partner ali or my children
and you know
they always get responded to even if
officially i'm off the grid
but the other thing i will do is i will
uh say to people
i'll be unavailable next week
and then i'm really unavailable
when you look back at the sabbaticals
you've taken right so
nine or ten two-month sabbaticals now
when you look at these sabbaticals that
have recharged you the most
versus the sabbaticals that have
recharged you the least
do you see any
patterns or do you see any
characteristics
that have some
explanatory power for you
that's a really really great question
this past sabbatical was incredibly
recharging
and um
you know it came after the
year that time forgot you know 2020
and um
the
in 2020 i bought um i got into cycling
and um
[Music]
as i said in my away message during this
past sabbatical i said
something like um
may your summer be filled with fireflies
and s'mores
for me i hope to have it filled with
weeding in my garden
and cycling in the mountains
and writing and working i'm working on a
new book
and working on my new book
and uh i slept
well
i ate well
and i rested
well
and i exercised my mind
was a new book
and i traveled i saw a family that i
hadn't seen in 18 months
i spent two weeks on the coast of
california and a lovely beach house
and my kids each came to visit and
cycled through
um which was lovely and
that so if i would say there's a pattern
of of sabbaticals that are done right
it's um
it's a focus on mind and body
and it's resting both and taking care of
both
for sabbaticals that did not go so well
i
would say the pattern is to load it up
with expectations like i'm going to
finish a book
or i'm going to read this these 10 books
or
i'm going to write a new business plan
or
i'm going to travel to europe and see
all these friends and then travel back i
mean these are all examples that my
clients have given me
and
you know the number one rule
in sabbatical is sabbath
rest
rest the body needs rest the mind and
heart
need
rest
right
that's just that's the simplest way i
can put it for you
do you have
or could you tell us if if there are any
examples
any
examples of
epiphanies or
breakthroughs ahas of any type that
resulted from being fully rested when
you came back to quote unquote normal
life
the epiphany could have happened during
the sabbatical but let's just say
something
and what i'm trying to do here is you
know speak to people who
have disallowed themselves from taking
breaks to try to
sell
this might be the wrong way to approach
it but some of the payoff of resting
does that make sense to me it does it
does and i'm looking away and i'm
getting uncomfortable in my body because
what i'm feeling is the impulse which
i think you're giving voice to which is
to make sabbatical productive
right
and
ah
if that at all feels resonant
that's the problem
you know when i was saying before let go
of those expectations that's part of
what i'm talking about here
um
okay so there's an image that i write
about in my first book uh something that
occurred to me in 2001 when i was lying
on the
ground at the bottom of the grand canyon
which by the way if you really want to
disconnect go to the bottom of the grand
canyon
you're four billion years into the past
it's an extraordinary experience and i'm
lying on the beach there may or may not
have been um some alcohol involved
and i'm staring up at the sky
and someone lying next to me says oh
shooting star
and i begin trying to stare at the
shooting stars
and i'm looking and i'm looking and i'm
looking and it's driving me crazy
because i can't see them
and then finally someone says stop
looking for them
and i rest my eyes
and with peripheral vision this is true
fact all of a sudden i can start
catching the motion
and that's an image i would give you for
sabbatical
people who go into sabbatical with the
plan too hey i'm going to lose 10 pounds
b i'm going to get into real good shape
see i'm going to finish that book
typically after
farting around for a week not getting
anything done start to feel terrible
and then it becomes this like voice of
you're wasting time i can't believe you
did this what's the matter with you
you're failing at sabbatical
right which is insane
but if we go back to that notion of
sabbath
which is you know in the jewish
tradition you know
uh disavow or disconnect from anything
that is electrical right put your keys
down put your money down
rest
there's something very very profoundly
holy
in rest
now i know i'm swimming upstream
everybody wants to be productive
i could also just if you don't mind me
playing
stand-in for the listener i could also
say well you spoke about this hot cold
boredom and even if you don't say i'm
going to finish the book the fact of the
matter is you you're writing
working on a book
and likely on some level feeling
productive so if we removed that
would you have needed an alternate
activity which i don't make wrong by the
way
but one could say hey you're a writer
you're working on books
you're saying we don't need to be
productive but i bet you feel productive
after a good day of writing what if i'm
not a writer
there may be people who would say
something like that sure
and i get that um
when i felt good
working on the new book this summer
it was
when i let go
of
the
production goals
some writers like to say you know
thousand words a day
you know 500 words a morning something
like that
and i
went into this past sabbatical with a
little bit of that mindset i'm gonna get
part one it's all mapped out i'm gonna
get part one done this summer
and i did hand in 15 000 words
of what will eventually be a 70 000 word
manuscript due next summer
and they were kind of a mess
as annie lamotte would say a shitty the
shitty first draft
but
my editor was able to sort of pull it
apart break it up into two chapters
which is a more appropriate status so it
was productive
but i was at my most productive when i
stopped trying to be productive i mean i
hate to sound zen-like here
but
you know it's it's all of the emotional
load that we put into that notion of
productivity that actually exacerbates
the the stress and tension that causes
us need to take the rest in the first
place
yeah
well let's
if i may
we can we can uh make this
personal on my side and we can we can
explore those muddy waters for a minute
uh so this i have been able
over the years to take
uh many trips and disconnect
typically for
uh particularly since i'm in an intimate
relationship with my
lovely long-term girlfriend we don't
like to be apart for long periods of
time
she
has a job
that
doesn't totally disallow but largely
disallows her to take the type of time
off that i might want to take off
for a sabbatical let's say nonetheless
we're able to take trips we took our
first trip
postcovid
just a few months ago and i was
effectively offline for
three weeks which was wonderful
and uh
i will take shorter trips and be
typically completely in the wilderness
or the jungle or somewhere with
nothing no electronics for a period of
time i do that generally at least once
or twice a year
nonetheless
what i have found for myself and some
people may resonate with this actually
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
give a few examples of friends and then
i'll give my personal example so there
are friends who have been in
zero sum games for so long that that
lens has become their default right so i
would argue that in some
startups at certain stages if you're the
ceo and you took a week off
things would blow apart like i do think
there are certain scenarios in which
that's the case
however
let's say you you ride that hundred foot
wave
you have some wonderful exit in the case
of a founder
they think they will just be able to
turn off that
script and
i have seen close to zero examples of
them being able to right it's very
common or i have a friend i i i shan't
name but very good friend
and we've known each other very long
time and i've watched as his magical
number right this number one right x
right then i'm going to build a
workshop in my garage and make
artisanal rocking chairs or whatever the
hell
and i've seen that number move and move
and move so every time he gives me some
new number i'm like yeah i've heard that
before great where i was talking to a
friend who
said i'm never starting x type of
podcast again he's done this twice now
and i'm like yep i've heard that before
and
he said something to me which i thought
was interesting it's not totally
germaine here but maybe we'll tie into
it we were texting and he said
i suppose that i just needed i need a
target for my free-floating anxiety yes
and i
identified with that quite a bit i said
you're right i mean you it's a lot
it's reassuring in some perverse way to
have an external
object or circumstance you can point at
and say that explains why i have this
really uncomfortable feeling inside
right
so i'm going to
park that for a second
because this is all a way of me sort of
backing into my own personal experience
so when we last spoke
and i thought hot damn this is something
we should talk about on the podcast
what i had realized for myself is not
that i can't take
time off or that i can't
i can't ignore the inbox or refuse to
reply on
the vast majority of things that come in
what i simultaneously have realized is
that
over the last say 10 or 15 years there
has been a creep of complexity
so when you have
dozens of different entities
llc's and so on when you have
hundreds or at least a hundred different
investments and funds and capital calls
and this that and the other thing and
you've added people to your organization
so you have more head count there is a
certain
amount of complexity that comes with
that so
while there are
a million emails i can i feel like i can
safely ignore there are certain others
from
whether it's a tax authority or
some registered agent or an employee
that i do feel like i should keep track
of or there will
there will ultimately be some
consequences uh
to ignoring those things and so
this is a very roundabout way of
asking how you have seen people
either
reframe the complexities so that it has
less of a
[Music]
fearful impact
on them or
and or reduce complexity
in a way that
lessens this sort of
internal drama that they experience
going along with it
i love the way you frame that question
and um
[Music]
there are tips and tricks and hacks that
you can do to reduce the complexity
but
the complexity will creep back
and i think you know this because you've
experienced this and we've had
conversations over the years about that
tension between those two spaces
i hire an assistant and then all of a
sudden i need to
and then i need five
and now they need to be responded to
right and it goes and so
let's take us all the way back to one of
jerry's very very famous questions which
is how have i been complicit in creating
the conditions i say i don't want
i like that you just referred to
yourself like the hulk uses
a third person
hulk mod
smash
how am i complicit in creating the
conditions i say i don't want right and
so i'm going to
alter that just slightly what benefit do
i get
from the conditions i say i don't want
what benefit do i get
from the conditions i say i don't want
and so let's turn it back to the
question so you create these really
complex structures
and you probably spend an enormous
amount of energy
sorting them out responding them maybe
even use autoresponders tax person go
here kind of thing
so if you want to alter that behavior
you have to understand what the benefit
is to you right the payoff or the
secondary payoff that's it what's the
secondary payoff what's the secondary
benefit and for you
what does it make you feel like
living a very complex life with hundreds
of investments and lots of fingers and
multiple pies and doing all sorts of
things what does it do for you
so i've uh
i thought about this and i would say
that i think the
complex structures are a side effect of
something else i don't think that i
actually get
much payoff from the complicated
structures but i think they're a symptom
and i would say
that for much of my life i had
competitive athletics and other things
that
consumed in a very good way i think a
lot of my focus and provided a lot of
excitement
just as important
excitement and
i haven't had that in a very long time
after a shoulder reconstruction and then
elbow surgery and
twisted this eye joint and all these
things i'm like you know what maybe i
don't need to get heal hooked today
maybe i don't need to get thrown on my
head in judo class this week
and i've stopped a lot of that
and i think in lieu
of that i enjoy competition i enjoy it
and i don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with that
i actually really really enjoy
competition and i think i'm a good
competitor in a lot of ways so i've
shifted the arena from sports and all
these other things art although i
haven't treated art competitively but
these activities and
substituted in
investing
and i've substituted in
uh different types of projects that
often have some creative component
almost always they do whether it's deal
structuring or
a podcast episode or a pre-loading
podcast that i can do a b and c
elsewhere but very often i would say the
investing side in particular is related
to excitement
i would say that's what i get from it
and the side effect of having
lots of investments
and lots of
things that come along with that
is this complication the complexity and
the systems that makes sense to me
what's the opposite of excitement
the opposite of excitement would be
boredom which is why i wrote down this
hot and cold boredom for you
that you mentioned earlier i think it's
boredom i think it's
and i'm not you know i used to be more
maybe optimistic about this
i mean i am sure fundamentally it comes
down to
not wanting to be alone with my own
thoughts and certain feelings that might
come up right
uh so the question of you know what is
it that you are unwilling to feel
yeah
i think it was tara brocco said you know
one sage said there's only one question
that matters what are you unwilling to
feel
and i've spent a lot of time thinking
about that i've spent a lot of time
working on that and i've also
arrived at a point where i'm i i've
looked at my family and i went to a
family wedding recently and i'm like
okay this could all be nurture maybe
it's just
behaviors that have been passed down the
bloodline
that's one
explanation it could also be that our
code
our dna just leads us to have a certain
baseline of
anxiety or depression or any number of
other things and
maybe i'm exerting a lot of calories
trying to
prove to myself that that is not the
case
you know tim
the thing that occurs to me every time
we talk is how much self work you've
done
and i'm going to make you feel really
uncomfortable because i'm really [ __ ]
proud of you
thank you jerry
you go there
so we're going to go there
uh it you know the the proclivity to
anxiety could have a genetic component
here but the proclivity to be
uncomfortable with what the buddhist
would call hot
boredom
is not dna
it's you know to use the term from my
first book it's a subroutine
it's programming
it's nurture
and
you said
kind of offhand but really with a kind
of self-awareness
okay so i'm uncomfortable perhaps with
boredom because i don't like to
necessarily be alone with my own
thoughts or to to face those things
and god bless you you've done a
fantastic job of learning to deal with
your own thoughts
so let's imagine if you will
that the learned behavior was boredom
bad
hulk
boredom bad
well the learned behavior may just as
equally have been the family saying we
don't want to actually be
with these questions
we don't want to be alone with our
thoughts collectively
because when we're alone with our
thoughts bad things happen
so let's get busy
yep and let's
make sure that we're
competitive and complicated and busy
with lots and lots of different things
so that we don't have to feel those
things over here
to to go back to tara brock
family systems
can reject
feelings
not just individuals
yep
right it reminds me about i remember
sitting with a group of uh executives at
a company and
they asked me to just observe their
executive team and i was watching and
something came up it happened once it
happened twice it happened the third
time and what it was was any time that
there was a really moment of tension
somebody would make a joke
and the whole energy would dissipate
and when i called it out the ceo said
that's just like my sunday afternoon
family dinners
and
sometimes
we get really complicated and busy
because we don't actually want to feel
what those thoughts
bring up
and there again
is a reason why
sabbatical can feel really challenging
because if i pause
i'm going to feel really uncomfortable
i'm going to feel
hot bored
can you
expand on hot boredom and then i'm going
to come back to what we're talking about
but could you just explain
the difference between hot boredom and
cold boredom or the spectrum of boredom
yeah yeah so hot boredom and cold
boredom is a really great uh framing to
to think about
we don't really do this so much anymore
but imagine you're online at the post
office or online at the dmv
and it's just an interminably long line
and you got to be someplace else
and
there's nothing to distract you
and that discomfort that's hot boredom
that's like it's literally my body
starts to feel achy and all that stuff
but contrast it to cold boredom
and i know you've done meditation
retreats imagine
not the first three or four days of
meditation retreat which often provokes
hot boredom
right what the hell am i doing here i
gotta i can't even sleep it's dinner
but by the day four day five day seven
day ten
you're sitting there and literally
there's nothing dramatic
going on in your mind
there's no drama
and you're okay
and
all of a sudden you catch a glimpse of a
bird that's really interesting
that's cold boredom
and i would argue that the mind
needs cold boredom
it needs those days of
simple
you know my therapist calls it just
simple stirring the oatmeal kind of
morning here i am do do just turn the
oatmeal
ah
because that's a moment of rest
from which we can then
go about
the rest of our time the rest of our day
i have many questions
as one would expect if i invited you on
the podcast to talk about this
let's start with
a hypothetical situation so i and i'll
tell you something that i haven't talked
about much
maybe not at all publicly but i've spent
the last i would say year
sitting with a lot of void very
deliberately not committing to any big
projects and it has been
one of the most difficult
painful experiences of my life
and
i threw every tool in my toolkit at it
meditating do it twice a day do it three
times a day take two weeks in the in the
wilderness i threw everything i had at
it and ultimately decided
sitting with this void for this long is
actually not good for my mental health
[Music]
and
i still haven't
prematurely committed to something huge
just to commit but
i i got to a point where sitting with
that void
felt unhealthy
and so my my question to you and i'm not
i'm not at the point of total burnout
but if if you're talking to a client
who
like it or not is not going to
get to a place of comfortable
cold boredom before they burn out and
you jointly decide or or he or she
decides they're going to take a
sabbatical so they have yet to become
sort of comfortable stirring the oatmeal
but they're going to take a sabbatical
what advice do you give to that person
um start small start with tiny steps
you know um when you're talking about
baby steps
how about starting with a weekend
how about starting with one evening you
know i mean literally
you were
you asked me before about the
when i started
sabbaticalizing
and um it it feels so long ago and it
feels so natural to me that i actually
forgot
what really began this
and it was something that you said where
you talked about going going off into a
jungle going into a forest and something
for for the 10 years previous to me
taking two months sabbatical
i would take
monumental off the grid trips why were
they monumental because that was the
only way it could really break
being attached to the grid
because if you go to as i did you know
across the polar ice cap in greenland
for some reason you don't get a good
sell signal it's like it's amazing um
you you are forced or you know i went
rafting the futalafu river in in the
chilean patagonian
area and there really isn't a good wi-fi
signal and it's beautiful
and so those small little steps i i have
a client i just started with in
september
and he's taking his first vacation
two weeks in namibia
first vacation in 10 years
first vacation in 10 years
it was only because his life partner
recently sold her business
and that they
have they feel like they have the time
that's not healthy
and so so practical advice start small
start where you are start with
a day
you know our mutual friend brad feld was
the first person i know
who used the notion of digital sabbath
right i'm gonna turn off the devices
from friday till sunday night
and just
i'm just not available and train the
people in my life to know that that is
happening
just start just start there
just start there
so let's say you've taken some baby
steps
and i'll tell you what i've run into
when i try
and i have i've taken
time
off of my or away from my normal
routines in say a city like austin
here's what happens to me
let's just say so i'm sitting downtown
in austin right now
i take i decide i'm going to take a
couple couple of weeks away from my
normal routines but i'm going to stay
here in so-called civilization
my girlfriend meanwhile is going to
continue with her normal routines
most of my friends
at least here
are not going to be
coincidentally taking
a sabbath a sabbatical the same time
that i do
and so i i go about my day
and ultimately
a it's very lonely
b
i end up feeling unemployed slash insane
because if you go to
the starbucks or you go to the library
or you go to
any number of other places
you end up surrounded in fact by a lot
of sort of unemployed
and or crazy people
i realized this in san francisco
actually right when i was like i'm gonna
take a break and i'm going to go to the
library and read and i was like wow this
is actually very disturbing because this
is sort of the
halfway house during business hours for
a lot of unstable people and i found
that
pull towards like the river edge of
chaos not good for me
well what i also hear you doing was then
deciding that you were one of those
people
ah it's not so i mean there is that
i mean you know you're not unemployed if
you're not working i know i'm not that
but it's
i think we're all affected on some level
by the people we spend time around right
like if somebody were
this is an extreme example but just to
kind of
play out the the point if somebody
actually were
sitting inside an insane asylum i know
that's probably not the politically
correct term these days but like one
flew over cuckoo's next and you weren't
like working behind the desk you're
actually sitting in there and playing
chess with these people all day
uh or whatever it might be
i think that would affect
just about
anyone sure if they were exposed to that
right so when you when you go into some
of these public spaces or semi-public
spaces during business hours in a place
like austin that is also the case and
it's not limited to austin i mean if you
want it times 10 go to san francisco
sure so i don't automatically assume i'm
one of those people but my
instrumentation is very sensitive so i
do get
i do feel
impacted
by being in the settings and i think we
could treat these two things almost
separately there's there's being in
those settings and being affected by
those settings there's also just a
a genuine sense of loneliness yeah and i
know a lot of people who are
quote unquote free right who can work
wherever they want whenever they want on
some level
uh even if they're still
paying the bills by working consistently
but they are working from a laptop
somewhere without
people around them who are in a similar
situation yeah that it can be agonized
it can be agonizing how lonesome
that feels uh so so that's a big
mouthful i don't know if if you have any
thoughts yeah i'm glad you circled back
to the word lonely because you went
lonely unemployed insane and i zipped in
on insane
but but i think the loneliness we don't
have we don't have to rule out that i'm
insane we can leave that on the table
but i i think the lonely is is really
important and
you know
what you're helping me see is that my
lens is very much
affected by the fact that
on the spectrum i tilt toward its
introversion
so i don't quite have the same reaction
to the word lonely or alone
uh as say my daughter who is very much
an extrovert
and during the lockdowns
she would really yearn to be
outside with other folks
may i interject for one second yeah so
so i would actually consider myself very
introverted
but i would also recognize myself as
someone who almost
killed himself had a date on the
calendar to do so in college
i think in part as a as a byproduct of
certainly lots of factors but one of
them being i was i was alone and
isolated way way way too much
so
so i would consider myself an introvert
and yet at the same time
i have a lot of fear around
feeling alone which is actually very
different from being alone right if i do
one of those extreme trips which i don't
consider that extreme i actually
consider it a real return to
fundamentals but where i'm in nature
by myself i don't feel alone
in the same way that i feel alone if i'm
sitting in a starbucks with a bunch of
unstable
people sitting around me
with no friends who are following any
routine that's similar to mine i
appreciate that distinction i think that
that's really helpful and what i'm
feeling my way to and i can relate to
this is
there are certain mental states that are
reminiscent of the past states you know
as we've talked about before i two
i actually attempted suicide at 18.
and
you know in an odd way
i make my bed every day
and i make my bed every day because
that's what i learned when i was in the
mental hospital was that you make your
bed every day even if you do nothing
else even if you don't shower you make a
bed every day and so i make my bed still
to this day because if i don't it starts
to bring up those feelings that i might
end up back
emotionally in that place and so what
i'm hearing you say is
the fear isn't about being alone
so much
it's about feeling lonely
because that's the association back to
the depression that's right and the
suicidal impulses
and that's
a really good observation about yourself
and so i applaud you being able to say
to yourself okay as an alcoholic might
say i'm going to stay out of a bar
you're going to stay out of those
situations that can be triggering for
you and bring you back to some of those
states
and i like where we are right now
because what we're seeing is that
perhaps there's a little fear of cold
boredom
because it might
remind one of feeling lonely
maybe maybe i
maybe maybe i think that there could be
some overlap
but for instance if i go on
a
i'll tell you one of my happy places and
maybe that'll be a contrast so one of my
happy places would be
i go into the wilderness with a handful
of close guy friends
and
we have the shared privation of like
sleeping in a freezing [ __ ] cold tent
waking up and having shitty instant
coffee in the morning which is like the
best
best
in the world
and then hiking at altitude and feeling
like i'm just getting punched in the
lungs for like 12 hours taking a nap on
a mountain top and
having a fire at night to like thaw out
your feet and then going to bed and
the majority of the day there is no
talking right
that's great for me and and you're not
lonely
i'm not lonely i'm also not
hyper active right so it's like left
right left right left right kind of
march so i would consider that
maybe i'm just not understanding the
terminology correctly but i would
consider that that would seem to me to
be a form of of cold boredom that is
definitely a form of cold boredom and i
love that i find after four or five days
of doing that
even if i'm getting the shittiest sleep
you might imagine right three hours a
night
sleeping on a rock
side note i can i tell a funny story
just for just for a diversion so i i
went on one of these first outings with
a couple of
a couple of guys who were very
experienced outdoorsmen like
also a number of them
former uh professional level sponsored
athletes so i was already intimidated
and i was a
c-level
san francisco resident at that point
going up to high elevation and i asked
about bears because they were all eating
candy bars and all this garbage inside
the tent i said shouldn't we be
concerned about bears and they said ah
no and one of them said they're just
black bears
just and they're more likely to lick you
to death than hurt you relax and i was
like okay and sort of shamed into
silence so we go to bed and we're
sleeping all around the perimeter of
this large tent
and i wake up and it's close to a full
moon i wake up and
the tent's about four inches from the
side of my face and there's literally a
huge nose pressed to the tent
four inches from my [ __ ] face and
it's this
gigantic
bear
i'm not kidding first night first night
and i don't know
any of these guys except for like one
one and a half let's call it
and so i think to myself more likely to
lick me to death if i wake these guys up
on the first night i will just be
i will be shamed to death for the rest
of this trip
and so i don't say anything i'm i'm in
full
prey mode
every
every single
corner of my psyche just lit up on fire
can't sleep not surprisingly
i i it comes back a few hours later
and then uh in the morning we're having
our coffee
and uh i mentioned this and the same guy
who told me would lick me to death it's
like jesus [ __ ] christ man you gotta
let us know that kind of [ __ ]
and nonetheless after that trip felt
like i had taken a six-month vacation
well that you know i mean you just said
it you're i mean the the the experience
of resetting for you
wasn't something that's time delimited
right there were some some some core
components of it off the grid is a
really key component of it being with
people
that you can
physically be with for several hours but
not have to entertain with dramatic
thoughts and talk and talk
that nourishes you yeah you know being
in the land nourishes you being
physically in your body nourishes you
that is a sabbatical dude
yeah
so should i just keep it at that or
should i be able to do this in austin
despite the fears of
sitting in these sort of third non-home
locations because
i can i can convince some friends to go
into the mountains for a week
i can't it's harder for me to convince
friends inside a city to be like hey
let's just not do our usual stuff for a
few weeks
i totally get that and you know changing
physical location
is really important i just put a
reservation down on a sprinter van
you know from winnebago the revel
i can't wait to be able to climb into
that and i live in a 40 acre farm
right so
you know
with the woman i love and three horses
and an 18 year old cat
right um coyotes running across my
the pastures and
hawks and bert and eagles and stuff
but sometimes you you need to change the
venue sometimes you need to change it up
and i i get that
i paused and hesitated tim because you
said should i
and you know me well enough to say i'm
not so sure i can answer i should
should you yes should you know
i think you have to go you have to
design it for yourself
you have to sort of tune into what you
know and
you know collect the information as you
have been doing and design your own
retreats
i find it enormously helpful
to be able to periodically even within
the envelope of my normal days
to be able to cut the chatter
right
i often say that you know i sit on the
meditation cushion because during the
morning
because i need to be able to meditate
throughout the day i need to be able to
return to that state of mind
so
you know go to the mountaintop for a
week at a time
so that
in an afternoon while stuck in the
middle of austin
you can go for a bike ride you can go
for a hike
you can go to a park
you know you can take a dog for a walk
you can do the things
that nourish you
if you can't
be off the grid for two months at a time
and very very few people can
then go off the grid
for hours at a time
that's all
you know
i think ultimately take the sabbatical
with you take that mindset with you
into and live it into your days
thank you jerry uh that that resonates
with me
uh
and i meditated this morning um
20 minutes nothing fancy
no drama just tm repeating some sound in
my head so that my monkey mind has
something to do climb up and down the
pole for 20 minutes that's it
and
it's so that i can remember for the rest
of the day ideally what it feels like
not to rush right that's it for me
largely that's it
are there any resources that you might
suggest to folks who are
considering the possibility of a
sabbatical i remember there's a book
that i
read i want to say this was around 2004
2005
called six months off
and i'm sure a lot of it is dated but it
was focused on different approaches to
taking
sabbaticals are there any other
resources and these could be non-obvious
resources could be a story a poem a book
a movie
doesn't matter are there any resources
that you might recommend
well one of my
little mental tricks that i do when i
when i do a public talk is i often open
up the talk simply by asking people how
are you
right and
that's the question by the way that
typically gets people crying
and
then i throw up a couple of different
words
you know excited scared
and almost always i land on the word
exhausted
and everybody just resonates with that
like your your your shoulders just
dropped as soon as i said the word
exhausted
because you you know what i'm talking
about it's just this constant sense
and
you know there is a blessing and i'm not
going to recall the fullness of it but
john o'donoghue the great irish poet the
late irish poet has a book of blessing
called
to bless the space between us
and in it he has a blessing
for those who are exhausted
and
in that blessing among the things he
says is
steer clear
of those vexed in spirit
so think about those folks in the
starbucks their vexed in spirit
and
become inclined
to watch the rain
and it's kind of a guidepost
you know if we think about sabbatical as
a sabbath time as a holy time
it's a holy time for those of us who are
exhausted
and that's the time
to rest
right i mean
whether you follow
judaism or christianity the
in the story
from the old testament
and on the seventh day even god himself
rested
right
easy
gentle
now there's another line from that poem
in which odania says
be excessively gentle with yourself
so i don't have
10 tips and tricks to make your
sabbatical
as productive as possible you know me
that's not the way my brain is organized
you saw the draft of my next blog post
for titans for sabbatical
yes sabbatical edition
volume one yeah
but i but but i think that there's there
is a really profound wisdom in odonius
poem which is
easy easy this is about a time to take a
breath
and you know when you i love the image
of you hiking with you know and and
camping and being out in in the land
with your friends
that's what you're doing
right rest is not
you know zonking out on the couch to
netflix latest binge watching streams
squid game something right rest
is turning the brain off
it's getting the heart rate down
it's it's taking care of yourself
and to me that's what sabbatical is all
about
yeah i suppose it could take different
forms right like in my case at high
elevation i'm actually
really physically taxing myself but it's
a
it's a for me it's a
it's a pure
exhaustion yes it's not a paper cut
exhaustion it is a pure
focused
holistic
deliberate exhaustion and
that's a straightening through fire of
sorts yeah listen i i'm all for
the physical exhaustion
as long as the mental turn-off is
happening as long as the mental
the chatter you called it the monkey
mind as long as the chatter is quieted
because i'll bet you when you guys are
hiking and you know you're you're going
from one camping spot to another
your minds are quieted
oh yeah yeah yeah even as your body is
physically taxed
yeah it's a different experience
well jerry
we're coming up on time for both of us
for different reasons
[Laughter]
and
i
would like to
read a name and you can tell me the
pronunciation and if you have this in
front of you i would love for you to
read this but if not i can read it
and that is
lost by david wagoner
is that correct that is correct
w-a-g-o-n-e-r
and
i i'm happy to read but if you have it
since you sent it to me
i feel like it makes sense for you to
read this because i think it
encapsulates a lot of what we're talking
about
and
could be a good place to
bookmark us for
this conversation sure
our
conversation won on sabbaticals but
moreover all of the
questions and queries and
introspection that can surround
the idea of a sabbatical
i can read it
i'm just bringing it up right now
yeah please
here we go
lost
by david wagner
stand
still
the trees ahead and bushes beside you
are not lost
wherever you are is called here
and you must treat it as a powerful
stranger
must ask permission to know it
and be known
the forest breathes
listen
it answers
i have made this place around you
if you leave it
you may come back again
saying
here
no two trees are the same to raven
no two branches are the same to ren
if what a tree or a bush does is lost on
you
you are surely lost
if what a tree or a bush
does is lost on you you are surely lost
stand still
the forest knows where you are
you must let it find you
so good so so good i'm so glad you sent
this to me this this is basically
the north star
for me
something along these lines for the last
few years and uh it's funny how
easy it is
for me anyway to lose sight of that
north star but how corrective it is as
soon as i realign and spend time
recognizing it again yeah
well i appreciate you giving me the
opportunity to read it and i would not
have missed that opportunity because
i think as you can tell reading poetry
is
one of the ways that i reach a sabbath
state
[Music]
so many things to talk about jerry
but
great to see you my friend
and
we will catch up again separate
from the recording
and
i will just let everybody know for
people listening you can find
jerry's book reboot subtitle leadership
and the art of growing up wherever books
are sold he's been on this podcast
before you can find more of jerry at tim
dot blog jerry colonna on twitter at
jerry colonna c-o-l-o-n-n-a
reboot at reboot hq on twitter and the
website reboot reboot.io
jerry is there anything else you would
like to say before we
hit pause on this conversation
just that i hope that uh
folks take a little bit of time off
and take a little bit of rest and and to
to remember the words from john
o'donoghue
be excessively gentle on yourself
good advice for me also to hear and
remember so thank you jerry i really
appreciate you thanks for having me on
tim it's always a delight to hang out
with you be well
you too and everybody listening we'll
have show notes links to everything at
tim.blog podcast and until next time
be gentle with yourself
you